all right so I just want to recap a few
of the topics that Sasha covered this
morning the motivation I guess for
uniform Wars of large numbers so so
remember and end to remind you of some
of the some of the notation that we're
using so remember we're talking about
restricting our attention to a class of
functions at we have some sort of a
choice from that class which we denote F
hat n that's based on the the sample for
x1 y1 through xn YN and the particular
choice that we're considering here is
when we minimize the empirical risk so
the sample averages of the lot for
losses we're using this notation P n of
the loss which denotes the empirical
distribution over these XY pairs right
so the sample average and we're writing
this kind of operator notation the David
Pollan notation you know P n of L and
we're interested in this sort of fam you
know choose FN hat from our class f in
this way and we want to know how close
we get in how close the population loss
is to the best we could have done given
though a restricted to choosing
functions from the class F all right so
it's this difference we care about and
you remember that of course there's an
approximation error term there you know
if the class is small then maybe L of F
sub F is pretty terrible right maybe the
best performance we can expect from a
perceptron is is hopelessly bad we're
sweeping that under the rug that's a
separate piece right and just interested
in how how closely we approximate the
best in in that class and we saw that we
had you know the expectation over the
sample of the risk for this empirical
risk minimizes the best in the class is
upper bounded by this expectation of the
deviation between the expectation of the
loss for that empirical risk
minimization
about this kind of quantity of course we
have to be careful you know this FN hat
is chosen using the data so it's chosen
to minimize this quantity so of course
it's going to be biased
and one way to get over that and
understand you know what sort of
deviations we should expect on the right
hand side and therefore what sort of
upper bounds we can get on the the
excess risk for our classes capital F is
to work with uniform balance on these
deviations right look for insure look
look for properties of the class that
that ensure that the maximum over the
class of these kinds of deviations
between expectations and sample averages
is not too big okay so you know this
really is an inequality will see some
cases where it's a tight inequality but
it's an inequality to keep that in mind
we're always getting upper bounds here
and then there's this nice empirical
process story to simplify things we're
going to step a little bit in the
abstract direction and say okay we know
there's an underlying loss function
we're talking about XY pairs and so on
but we we just want to consider you know
these are the this is the the set of XY
pairs this is the class of loss
functions right mapping from XY to the
loss that's incurred when you use f to
predict so we have a class of functions
on some domain and we're interested in
when expectations and sample averages
are uniformly close across that class
okay so you know this is the this is the
broad topic that we're working with you
and there's this really nice cartoon
that that Sasha put together and showed
us we think of this axis as being all of
the functions that we're considering
this is the population case right the
expectation of the loss that's incurred
when we choose choose one of these guys
this is the the loss corresponding to
the function in the class I guess this
is all function so that this is the
Bayes prediction rule and this is the
the Bayes risk and you know there's the
empirical version of that we take sample
averages on our sample of size N and if
we minimize that or there's another
sample if we minimize this empirical
quantity we may end up with something
that looks really good on the sample but
actually it's pretty pretty terrible in
in terms of expectation and
and if instead we restrict to outs hard
to see that if instead we restrict to
this to it to a limited family then we
may do much better we may be able to
show that you know uniformly across that
family sample averages are close I guess
even for this family they're not that
not that close but it's a cartoon okay
so so that's the picture to keep in your
head let's get a little more precise so
we're talking about a class of functions
G defined on this space said their
functions are mapped to a bounded range
and I guess that's not there that's
going to be important when we yeah so so
we're assuming that these functions are
bounded you could you could relax those
assumptions we have a sample of size N
and we're considering something that's
identically distributed and and we're
interested in the worst-case over our
class of functions of deviations between
expectations and sample averages we
write that using this notation so P of G
means the expectation under the
distribution P of this function right PN
of G means the expectation under the
empirical distribution right the one
that assigns mass one over n to each of
these z1 through Zn and the deviation
between those two we're maximizing over
the class okay so we use this norm
notation and an empirical process sort
of notation so you know P minus PN we're
thinking of as this operator that acts
on functions U evaluated at a particular
function you get this deviation and then
the norm with the subscript G is saying
what's the maximum over that class of
these deviations right evaluated at some
particular G so this empirical pretend
and you know where we're interested in
when this quantity is going to zero
right as the sample size grows and
that's called the uniform law of large
numbers because we're we're maximizing
across across the class if there were
just a single function it would be you
know regular law of large numbers and
we're wanting to make it uniform looking
at the
worst-case across all the functions in G
the randomness in you so if we look at
it look at it here that's deterministic
right that's just an expectation this
thing involves the random sample said 1
through Zn right so this this is a
random variable because it depends on
those red ones residents and and you
know often will be concerned with
expectations actually we'll we'll make
some statements about high probability
bounds as well but you know to say that
actually these things are with high
probability close to expectations or
we're really going to focus on these
expectations there's another layer there
that we're kind of sweeping under the
road is there another question ok so so
a little more terminology we defined we
say that this class is a global Co
Cantelli class for a particular
probability distribution if this supreme
across the class of deviations between
expectations and sample averages
converges to zero so just you know so we
have all of the notation on one slide
this is a probability distribution on on
Zed we see a sample of size n drawn from
that probability distribution that
sample defines the empirical
distribution which puts mass 1 over N at
each of these sample points we've got
our class G of real valued functions I
guess bounded real valued functions on
on the set Z and the empirical process
here is P n minus P so it's a stochastic
process index by a class of functions
you know a function that takes you from
a random function that takes you from
functions in g2 to real numbers and and
and we're using this norm notation
you know the maximal deviation between
expectations and sample averages over
the class G ok so we're going to use
that sort of notation we call it a go
Vanko Cantelli class because you know
this is a
can tell a theorem the the the result
that they proved was for a special case
of of one of these uniform laws of large
numbers that were saying if you talk
about a cumulative distribution function
for a random variable that's f right so
that's the probability that the random
variable so f at a is the probability
that the random variable is is less than
or equal to a right so it's this it's
this function that increases from 0 to 1
f sub n is the corresponding empirical
quantity so instead of the probability
that it's less than or equal to a it's
the proportion of of a sample of size n
that's less than or equal to a right so
it's a step function right rather than
some nice cumulative distribution
function
all right that's written out here and
and if these zared 1 through Zn are iid
with with a distribution that has this
CD F capital F then and this is the
uniform norm right the supremum across
all all real t of f t- up here it's FF t
minus FN t then you know this thing is
saying we want our empirical CDF to be a
uniformly good approximation of the true
CDF that generated these these Z is
that's a special case of agloe Vanko
Cantelli class where the class here is
these these functions are the step
functions right parametrized by the the
real value alpha ok because you know
we're interested here in the sample
average of the indicator for being
smaller than T you know that's smaller
than some real quantity so if we can say
uniformly across this class G we have
expectations close close to sample
averages that's exactly the Glencoe
Cantelli theorem so that's that's where
the GC terminology comes from and for
this special case you know that's a
that's a one layer neural network with
one input
and monotonicity can strap positivity
can strain on the parameter okay so you
know obviously not everything is a is a
globe echo can tele class so for
instance if we consider the class of
indicators for being an element of a
particular finite set so for every
finite set right every finite subset of
the reals this defines a function that
map's to 0 or 1 but but that's certainly
not a GC class we don't have uniform
convergence of expectations to sample
averages if you fix one of those
functions for every probability
distribution you know you you have a law
of large numbers right the indicator for
one of these sets the the probability
that you fall in that set is well
approximated by the the sample average
as n gets large but it's certainly not
true uniformly and for instance if you
have a continuous distribution then this
expectation is zero for because you're
hoping to fall in this finite set with a
continuous distribution but the supremum
right over over finite sets of the
empirical the the sample average is 1
right you just pick that set to be the
the set that you saw on the sample so
you know we have always have a big gap
between between these two so yeah so
there's a law of large numbers but
there's not a uniform law of large
numbers okay so and that's because you
know this is just too much
right this is this is a set of functions
that's too rich ok so what's what's not
too rich well the there's a notion of
complexity that really tells the whole
story will see that uniform convergence
is equivalent to a property of a set
defined in terms of these rate America
averages so let's get some you know it's
quite an intuitive idea let's get some
intuition about random accro averages on
a finite sample so rather than functions
let's think about subsets
of bounded interval a cube right in in
in n dimensions so think of that as you
know fixing the sample let's say Zed 1
through Zn and and considering functions
restricted to that so they're just
vectors in RN fine and for those
function values that we see we're going
to think of them as you know a subset of
RN and we're going to measure the
complexity or the size of that subset by
the average length of a projection onto
a random direction so our random
Direction is given by this vector
epsilon epsilon 1 through epsilon n
these are symmetric independent plus
minus 1 random variables random akha
random variables and and we consider
this random acker process which is a
function that maps from RN to to the
reals so given a vector in RN for
instance you know one of these one of
these guys in our set h RN hat of h is 1
over n times the inner product between H
and this random direction
ok so we're saying you know this this
router maker process is picking a random
direction and seeing how much it lines
up with H in an average way we scale it
by 1 over N okay and we're interested in
the taking the supremum over the set of
how much we align with that with that
particular H and then you know on
average what's the expectation this
expectation of course is over you know
we're fixing an H this expectation is
just over the epsilon right so we use
this this notation to say conditional
expectation where you fix everything
else in and just average out over the
epsilon
all right so these are the random acre
averages and the intuition is you know
if H is small then then somehow you know
pick a random Direction you're not going
to be able to find anything in H that
lines up with that particular direction
you know in where small means you know
not filling out much of our n in some
cents okay that's the hand-wavy
intromission we'll go through a few
examples but let me pause there for
questions ya supposed to save you good
good question
nothing special they convenient to work
with right we could work with uniform on
the sphere we could work with Gaussian
random variables and you could relate
all of these things so for in particular
you can relate them because for instance
for uniform on the sphere you have a
symmetry property for gaussians you have
a symmetry property you can split those
random variables into a product of a
plus or minus one like this and they're
just and then direction
you know random random direction I guess
scale as well with a with a Gaussian and
they're related to each other right so
so there's an analogue of these random
akhrot averages in terms of gaussians
called the Gaussian averages and
Gaussian complexity and it's closely
related to the random acreages you know
bounded by a constant on one side and a
log factor on the other side you know
similar similar story applies in the
case of spherical and I haven't worked
it out but you know I would guess in
that case you'd get a constant on both
sides it's got to be true homework
exercise right so you know yeah that's a
good question there's nothing special
but these are these are kind of
convenient convenient to work with
whistles okay so let's think about a few
a few examples so let's think of our set
in RN as being just a single vector H
zero points this way and and now we're
interested in the radio micro averages
the expectation of the H in that set
that maximally aligns with with with an
epsilon vector write a random corner of
the plus/minus 1 cube right so you know
because we're putting the absolute
values in there we're just saying you
know you want to know what's the average
alignment between a fixed direction and
this random random vector we get
something that's it's not zero but it's
close to zero right it's like 1 over
square root of n ok the expectation
without the absolute values of course is
0
we've got absolute values in there get
something that scales like this if we've
got on the other hand you know something
that's kind of n dimensional in
particular the plus or minus 1 n cube
the hypercube with this symmetric thing
plus minus ones then of course you know
you give me a random epsilon vector of
plus minus ones I can align with it
perfectly right it's it's the inner
product is n we divide by n we get 1 all
right so this one's nice and small this
one's really very big and and the right
intuition to have is that this is sort
of filling out the whole of that N
dimensional space ok this one is not
it's pointing in one direction more
generally you know if we have a cube
like this that somehow embedded in our
set H right if contained in H there's
you know centered at some vector V
there's a little cube of scale C
somewhere there right then that's good
enough to ensure this sort of behavior
we get a constant appearing here
all right constants bad we want
something going to 0 so we had a
constant appearing here or at least a
constant appearing here who knows what
else is going on in age but at least
that constancy
appears so there's some sort of n
dimensional behavior embedded in this
set right here's this is the witness to
that n dimensional behavior and that's
why we get this sort of behavior okay
see if you're awake after lunch so what
happens if H is there all one's vector
together with the negative of that
vector so all one's and and the negative
of it so what's the what's the one of
the right emaki averages look like in
that case
watch
[Music]
exactly the same as the first case great
right because having one or the negative
of it we had absolute values in the
definition here anyway right so if you
aligned with this one the absolute value
means you're aligning just as well with
that one
it's no different from this case right
all right and and you know actually
we'll see I think it's on the next one
right so so if we have a finite set in
general we get that 1 over square root
of n behavior and and the the scaling is
like the log of the cardinality of the
class no worse than I should say the log
of the cardinality of the class okay so
so that's an upper bound the upper bound
can be really loose because you know
these things could be very similar in
some way we're not taking account of of
kind of the overlaps that we see in in
the elements of this of this class you
know and certainly we can come up with
infinite classes for which this is this
is a terrible bound you know we have a
nice small value of 300 micro averages
let's look at a couple of examples like
that so think about our subset of our
end being a unit ball in the P norm
right let's let's just say two norm
right so we're considering all vectors
in RN that have let's say two norm no
more than one then the random a
coverages in that case written it out
explicitly here right it's the one over
n times the expectation of the maximum
over this class of the alignment between
an epsilon between a random this plus
minus one direction and a G you know
this maximum of course is achieved when
you set G to be the epsilon direction or
the minus epsilon direction and then
scale it back to have unit norm all
right so you calculate that you get just
the norm of that epsilon vector which is
square root n so we get a 1 over square
root of n scaling in that case just like
we got when H was of cardinality 1
okay so there's a nice small class but
it's it's infinite uncountably infinite
so you know certainly taking the log of
the cardinality of that set is gives us
a bad off of em okay and you know you
can investigate other unit balls in
other other norms in the same sort of
way okay so what do they have to do with
this problem of uniform convergence
uniform moles of large numbers so we're
going to consider the subset of our n to
be the set of vectors that we get when
we evaluate functions in our class at Z
1 through Zn right so consider you know
our vector of length n is for every
function in our class we get a distinct
vector and the components are that
function evaluated at said 1 Z 2 or left
is it in alright so for that thing you
know and and here's a nice a nice
picture that Sascha drew right so we
have a bunch of functions here and we're
considering the vector of values of
those functions at all of the different
points that appeared in the sample said
1 through Zn and you know that gives us
for each function a particular vector of
real values and we're interests in the
router maker averages for that set of
vectors in RN
okay so if we fix those z1 through Zn
you know and consider the rata macro
averages of those things where where H
is that that set on the previous slide
right G evaluated at all of these ed one
through Z ends then we you know this
this empirical ratamacue process it's a
data dependent quantity because it
depends on the Z 1 through Zn we can
also define a random acre process that
doesn't have doesn't have the Hat so
when we could we're considering you know
expectation of the supremum over
functions in our class where this
expectation is over the z1 through Zn
and the epsilon s--
right so we can define another empirical
process the rate Omega process RN of G
without the Hat that's you know same
scaling and now it's how does G
evaluated outside 1 through Zn aligned
with the with the epsilon rise so you
know we have two kinds of notation this
one is for a subset of RN and this one
is for a set of functions alright so
this empirical process involves just the
epsilon eyes as its randomness this one
involves the X there's Zed eyes as well
okay so that's the that's the kind of
terminology we're going to use and it's
this quantity for a class of functions
that we'll see is is central to uniform
laws of large numbers
the Hat here is I guess the definition
isn't on the board it isn't on that
slide right and and that's probably a
confusing way to ride it because there's
a supremum over a class of functions
written up there the the RN hat
evaluated at an H for some subset of RN
so this thing is is just 1 over n sum
from 1 to n of epsilon I H I and for a
function G in this class G which maps
from some bounded subset of the reals
let's just write it as R all right so
this is a set of functions from from our
domain Z to the reals
and and the second one RN of G is
has two sources of randomness the
epsilon eyes and dead eyes right so you
know these are these are both random
functions of something
this one's randomness comes from just
the epsilon dice this one's randomness
comes from the epsilon eyes and the
sample okay
so we're going to look at proving a
uniform law of large numbers in in terms
of these kinds of quantities and and
we'll see you know that the the maximal
deviations between expectations and and
sample averages are very closely related
to to the suprema of these random occur
rather maker processes and you know
that's in expectation over what's random
and in this case you know it's the it's
the these guys that are random but in
fact all these things are tightly
concentrated about their expectations so
so we'll focus on just just proving
relationships between the expectations
of these things so here's the big
theorem you know really we should look
at it in stages there's an upper bound
that says you know for whatever your
class expectations of maximal deviations
across that class between expectations
and sample averages are upper bounded by
constant times their expectations of
Maxima of these rather macro processes
right so we get an upper bound on these
maximal deviations and given a bound on
the scale of our functions let's say
they they map to the interval 0 1 then
we also get a lower bound that's like
you know 1 over square root of n away
and a different constant factor but it's
essentially the same thing right so if
if you care about maximal deviations
between expectations and sample averages
that's equivalent to to these random
akha processors and you know all this is
true in high probability right that that
because we had things uniformly bounded
here map mapping to a bounded range or
you could relax that to be something sub
Gaussian and get and get the same rates
then you know these quantities are all
tightly concentrated so these things are
close to their expectations these things
are close to their expectations you know
everything's you can you can leave out
the expectation
you won't be far off probability okay so
we're not going to pay much attention to
do the high probability part and just
think about the expectation part okay so
so things are pretty much the same you
know if you're caring about Suprema of
these empirical processes then that's
pretty much the same as carrying about
Suprema of the ratamacue process this is
telling you that the bounds are are very
tight right you have this small constant
factor and and something that's like one
over square root of n but if you stop
and think about it you know even G
containing a single function we get 1
over square root of n here right so
we're getting we're getting something
that's never worse than another constant
factor in this lower bound and right so
so there's no room for for any looseness
if what you care about is the maximal
deviation between an expectation of
sample average over your function class
that wasn't you know what motivated the
study of this this was an up of this
quantity here was an upper bound on the
deviation between the performance the
expected loss of an empirical minimizer
and how good it looks on a sample the
sample average of that right that was
just an upper bound and in some cases as
Sascha mentioned in some cases that can
be quite loose there can be a big gap
there are examples and we'll see we'll
see several of them where actually you
know this quantity although it's just an
upper bound it's a tied up around on
that on that other quantity and
certainly you know this relationship
can't be improved this shows that you
know it's essentially saying these
questions
okay so so let's think about why that's
why that's true I think it's helpful to
think of this that you know it's really
a similar intuition to what was going on
I shouldn't say that to what could have
been going on in in Sasha's explanation
of the performance of the perceptron
algorithm right when you talk about its
performance on a an iid sample one way
of viewing the the analysis related
analysis to the one that that Sasha
showed is that actually you're just
swapping in and out the what you call
the test example and what you call a
training example and of course that has
exactly the same distribution right so
the iid assumption means we can switch
XY pairs around and it doesn't change
anything we have exactly the same
distribution so we're going to exploit
that here and that's where the the
radome a curve random variables come
from it's that symmetry of switching
things in and out right so okay so we're
looking at the expectations of these
maximal deviations I've just written it
out here but I've replaced the
expectation under P of this thing by an
expectation of another sample average
right so you know this is our this is
our sample this with the prime of Zed
one's prime through Zn Prime that's a
ghost sample and we're just averaging
across it so I haven't changed anything
it has of course the expectation of this
average is just the expectation okay but
now I can get an upper bound by pull by
pulling that expectation outside the
supremum this is certainly bigger right
know smaller and now I've got something
that's looking more symmetric and of
course I can I can write that you know
I'm taking an expectation of a
conditional expectation that's just an
expectation
all right that's this thing and I'm
going to use this notation P n prime for
this empirical distribution and P n of
course is our old empirical distribution
all right so so what I've shown is that
the these deviations not
much more than upper bounded I should
say by deviations between sample
averages and independent sample averages
okay but if you think about these in
particular these random variables they
have exactly the same distribution I
could have written them in the other
order and I've got something that has
exactly the same distribution right I
could have written them in any order
I've just rewritten that that line and
now I'm putting an epsilon I in here
which is plus or minus 1
I can choose whatever value I like for
epsilon 1 and I've got something that
has exactly the same distribution here
and so in particular exactly the same
expectation right I could choose
whatever value I like for epsilon 2 and
the same thing is true okay so I can
pick anything for these epsilon eyes and
and I have this equality I'm actually
going to do something else I'm going to
randomize the epsilon eyes and pick them
to be uniformly plus or minus 1 and I
have exactly the same inequality right
an expectation across a whole bunch of
equal things and and you know of course
these are our ratamacue random variables
and then we just do a little bit of sort
of approximating right once we have the
this quantity we can split these pieces
just use triangle inequality and say
when we've got that piece and we've got
an epsilon I times that piece and now we
can upper bound it by this piece plus
this piece which gives us these two and
of course that's twice the right amount
of complexity okay so that's the that's
the upper bound you know everything is
relying on the symmetry that we get from
the iid assumption
questions oh yeah good two places so
this triangle inequality is one that
introduces a constant factor right the
other place is this one where we pulled
the supremum inside the expectation okay
but you know somehow that doesn't hurt
right and we see it doesn't hurt from
the from the the opposite inequality and
and the opposite inequalities obtained
just by another triangle inequality that
we we can get an upper bound on the rate
of macro averages in terms of deviations
I won't go through it but it's really
just saying you know you can split
things by taking expectations in and out
using a triangle inequality and then you
know everything is kind of small this
this part gives you deviations between
sample averages and expectations and
this part small you can you know go go
look at the slide is a very very
straightforward argument I won't go
through okay so so so that's the result
I guess this is the line to look at
right that that if we're interested in
deviations between expectations and
sample averages maximal deviations
across a class then those things are
close to the Suprema
of the the supremum of this ratamacue
process across the class
okay probably a good point to pause any
questions about around America
complexity alright so let's get back to
our problem of losses you know the G has
just been for this part and abstract
class of functions to find on a domain Z
but actually we care about compositions
of losses with functions from some
particular class of prediction rules and
and you know for the G we have that our
maximal deviations are bounded by the
maximal value of this random echo
process and you know it involves losses
composed with functions and and you know
we're interested in the functions
themselves and what we can say about a
particular class of functions the L is
usually something that we can
conveniently get rid of for
classification in particular it's very
it's very easy so think about the case
of two class classification right so our
function class f is mapping from images
to cat or dog right our Y is is those
two classes our loss function is the
indicator for getting it wrong right but
we can write this as a in this sort of
linear form linear in whatever the
prediction is right and and because
these things take values either plus or
minus one you know if you just think
about those having the same sign or
different sign this is saying exactly
the right thing right it's one if
they're different at zero if they're the
same so so when we plug that into the
ratamacue averages the the ratamacue
complexity for the lost class right this
is our lost class for a particular
function f this is an element of the
lost class for this particular F so this
is the rate-o-matic complexity of the
loss composition of a loss in the
function but we can rewrite the loss in
this way that's linear in F
right for any given why it's just this
one - this product times are constant
and now of course we can split that up
you know this part is just the right
amount of complexity this part is just
some little little order 1 over squared
empty okay so the classification you
know we can essentially ignore this this
loss function it just changes things by
a constant and some small additive thing
less less clear for other other loss
functions we'll see we have to work a
little harder in other cases
okay so I wanted to step through a few
tools that give us for instance ways to
deal with other other kinds of loss
functions so in particular the key thing
that will well I guess we're going to
use all these but one of the things
we'll work with is what happens if we
have a Lipsius loss but let's step
through all of these things so so you
know the kind of mentality behind
listing a bunch of these properties of
random acha complexities is that we can
snap together different different pieces
to build up richer classes of functions
and and use that to get a handle on the
random act of complexity of a class of
functions by thinking of it as composed
in different ways from from different
pieces you know so for instance
obviously if we have a smaller set of
functions then we have smaller ratamacue
complexity just because we're taking a
supreme over a smaller set if we scale
things up by a constant right then we're
just scaling the whole thing up by that
constant right because because the
functions appear linearly in this thing
right it's it's a constant times the
function that appears in that in that
sum if we add in a constant a constant
function right so we have a class of
functions and we add in something that's
just a single fixed function it doesn't
change things by very much right changes
things by sort of 1 over square root of
n so no big deal to take any particular
fixed function
it's it's only changing the the right
amount complexity by an additive one
over screwed of n turf if we take a
class of functions and consider its
convex hull so linear combinations of
functions from that class where the sum
of the I guess I'm yeah convex hull
rather than centric so they'd say
positive weight linear combinations of
functions from that class where the sum
of the weights is one right then that
doesn't change the random macro averages
and that's because we're doing a
maximization of a linear quantity all
right so if you consider the convex hull
you know the maximum is going to be
achieved at the corners the boundaries
of that convector okay so so convex
hulls don't change anything and the last
one is you know thinking about what
happens when we have this sort of a
class and we want to consider you know
because we're interested in maximal
deviations across classes like this loss
functions composed with functions from
from some some class then you know
there's a there's a result that says as
long as this loss is 1 Lipschitz in in
the prediction right then we don't
change the row to make row averages by
much there's a constant factor and a
little 1 over square root of n appearing
okay so putting things through a
Lipschitz loss doesn't change things and
you know adding a constant here and
we'll we'll throw it in there just by
scaling
okay so these are property is a laundry
list of properties here and we're going
to we're going to see we can apply those
to get you know in a pretty easy way to
get try to make a complexity balance for
useful and interesting classes of
functions
all right so let's look at a very easy
example that's you know I guess much
more focused on the the deep network
side of things so deep networks we're
going to think of them as compositions
of nonlinear functions in particular we
might have each one of these layers
computed by taking a linear combination
a linear function of the vector input to
produce a vector output so W is a matrix
we pass that through a nonlinear map
that maps from vectors to vectors right
and and maybe it's the component wise
map where each component is the
squashing function like this this
sigmoid right well maybe these nonlinear
maps are this ramp they're going to be
this max of 0 and and that component so
this gives us a rally Network right for
rectified linear units so you know we
could imagine a network that's computed
in in this kind of a way the parameters
are these Wis right that's what changes
that the W's in each layer change what's
being computed and we think of these as
fixed nonlinearities ok so the classes
are functions like this what can we say
about the radda macro averages which is
equivalent to asking what can we say
about excuse me uniform deviations
between expectations and sample averages
over this class of functions
[Applause]
all right so let's think about the
sigmoid case first of all because it's
easier okay this is two-layer but just
because I was lazy you you know that the
same result applies with this too in
particular change to L if you want to
result for L layers so this is to layer
to layer networks with sigmoid
non-linearity so this Sigma here is has
a Lipschitz condition
let's say we've Lipschitz constant one
okay I'm making a pass through zero I
guess that's only important for
constants this is no big deal
and and I didn't write it anywhere here
but this is a sigmoid function that what
what else is important here is that this
this function actually maps to a bounded
interval in the reals right so it never
gets outside of let's say plus minus one
okay so that's missing from this slide
but essential fur for the argument on
your mate okay then for such a for such
a network so what is it doing it's it's
here's a bunch of parameters these vis
are vectors there are K of them Ches
Ches you know anything you like they're
as wide as you like and each one of the
vis has a one norm constraint and then
you've got this vector of K K output
weights they also have a one norm
constraint and and we have d dimensional
inputs right so the x's of the image or
I guess the V eyes are in Rd then the
random act of complexity of this class
is bounded by B squared times square
root D over square root log T over N
okay so we're paying a price so they you
know the the number of parameters can be
as large as you like a number of
nonlinearities where we're paying a
price in the scale of the of the
parameters okay so the the proof is
really just piecing together these these
kind of obvious properties of random act
of complexity so let's you know starting
from the input we can think about our a
particular class of functions that takes
takes you from a d-dimensional input
vector to just one component of that
vector alright so this is a class of
size D and then we can consider the
first layer functions before the
non-linearity right these things take
inputs and scale them linearly by
something that has a one norm constraint
of B right and we could rewrite that as
B times the convex hull of these
functions together with their negations
because you know we've we've got
absolute values here right we could we
could be in the positive or negative
direction so we need we need both
positive a negative excise and and then
we're taking the convex hull of these
guys right because we have a one norm
bound but it's a bound of B so it's the
be scaled convex hull we've written out
what the convex hull is okay and then
our class of functions you know is well
we take all of those all of those linear
functions right the V is from from this
class we pass them through a
non-linearity and then and then we take
another scaled convex hull so we could
write the whole thing as you know we've
got our class VB up here for the first
layer functions we scale that we compose
that with this non-linearity right and
then take the be scaled convex hull and
we have to consider negations again
right this is this is our original class
and you can see why I'm writing in
swaye right because we're going to use
all these little pieces to plug plug
things together and you know hopefully
you get the idea right so our class or
you can interested in its ratamacue
complexity we can write that as the
ratamacue complexity of this is the same
class it's the B scale convex hull of
possible negations of not only a
function computer that and these things
are the be scaled convex hull of the
inputs okay so you know scaling just
passes straight through this linear
thing right so we get the B coming out
here convex hull makes no difference
right the router macro averages for a
convex hollow equal to this union of two
classes I guess I never wrote this one
down but that's you know no more than
the sum to see that you're taking a max
over this over something in this and
something in this and down here we're
taking a max over something in this and
adding it to a max over something in
this so you know as long as these things
are positive we're just getting an upper
bound possibly losing a factor of two by
doing it and of course these are exactly
the same thing negations don't change
anything because of our absolute values
passing things through our Lipschitz
non-linearity is that contraction
inequality that I wrote in a special
form for loss functions but you know
it's true in this simpler form as well
and then just writing out what VB is
it's the B scale convex hull of the
inputs possibly negated again the B
passes through we get a B squared the G
Union blah blah blah right okay you get
the picture these this is a cardinality
2d class so let's stop there right we've
seen we get a log of the cardinality of
the class divided by n all square root
for this thing and so you know it's very
easy and you can imagine if you wanted
to go deeper then you get you know these
factor of two be appearing at each layer
right so you're raising this thing to
some to some power
it seems so insensitive to the
activation function all we're using is
this Lipchitz property we're using two
properties actually of the activation
function one is that somehow it spins
not too far from zero so I you know
that's been swept under the rug in all
of this but you know if you if you have
things that have a ridiculously large
scale you know that can affect things
right so so we need that it doesn't take
us from something near zero to something
very very far from zero so that's one
one thing I guess there are three
properties there's that we're using the
Lipchitz property which appears very
explicitly here and and we're using the
fact that well you know I guess it's
implicit we could think of it as just
those two properties no I'll stay quiet
about the other
it'll come up later I'm not making this
up I guess I am I've made it a murder
mystery now yes basically you're sitting
here suggesting that it'd be like
because Eve and it's harder to
generalize because power L that's right
yeah yeah you know the the bound gets
worse as we as we move up through these
these layers that's right you know the
place where where we have actual
inequalities here this one introduces a
factor of two okay so maybe there's
maybe there's a you know in that to be
to the depth that we see maybe the two
doesn't belong it right and in terms of
the B you know if you think of the
scaling end to end that's B to the depth
and and you know if you wanted to
rescale things that that's inevitable
right from the scaling or you have
inequality there random acre averages of
a scaled class is scaling times row
macro averages of the class so so that
part's also in some sense inevitable if
we're considering you know exactly this
class of functions we haven't lost very
much in that case but remember what it
is that this is equivalent to its
equivalent to maximal deviations between
expectations and sample averages across
the class so we're really using the
whole power of that class they're all
considering the whole power of that
class when we think about quantities
like this which may not be relevant to
the behavior of an empirical risk
minimizer okay so it may be that you
know you can find an empirical risk
minimizer that is actually has
expectations and sample averages closer
than the worst-case across this class
you know another way of viewing viewing
that is we could have a class that's
much richer than we ever need right so
you know this class is certainly
contained in some much bigger much
bigger class that satisfies to the class
of all functions that satisfy whatever
lis into n Lipschitz constraint this
this class satisfies and then things
would get you know hugely more complex
we'd get we'd get the dimension
appearing in an exponential way for that
class you know if we went through and
did calculations of this sort
so we're considering something much
bigger than we actually need to consider
okay yeah we saw that too concerned
about that okay so that was sigmoid
networks
what about rellis I guess the
the sigmoid non-linearity
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna skip over this
when we're so actually this slide is
referring to a quite different technique
from the one I want to show you so let's
skip on to that all right so so we can
use a specific property of the relu
non-linearity so this piecewise linear
non-linearity we can use a specific
property of that to give us to give us a
bound on the the random anchor
complexity and this is a nice a nice
simple simple argument for this so the
property is that that we can pass
constants through the Rayleigh
non-linearity so if you think about this
function that's the zero function to one
side of zero and then identity function
to the other side if you scale inputs by
by a constant that's the same as scaling
outputs by a constant right because it's
a piecewise linear piecewise homogeneous
linear function okay so we can we can
scale up the output to have exactly the
same effect of scaling up the input so
we'll use that to to show this result
stated as a high-probability found why
is that yeah so so ignore the high
probability statement this is just an
expectation of this this supremum of the
rate-o-matic process so we're just
working in expectations this was
corrected and this wasn't apologize for
that so okay so the router maker
complexity of this this class which is
I'll explain in a moment this class of
relu networks is bounded by something
like B to the depth over square root of
n and we could have stopped it l equals
two and you know I could have waved my
hands in the same way as for the sigmoid
case this network has you know it has an
F down here for Frobenius and a B
for the bound so we've got a bound on
these the scale of these weight weight
matrices the sigmoid the Sigma function
is the the relu so it's a 1 Lipschitz
positive homogeneous function applied
component wise to its its input vector
and these Wis
satisfy a Frobenius norm constraint
right so the scale of these matrices is
bounded by B okay so you know the result
is loose in the sense that we're working
with a Frobenius norm there are zero you
know tighter results than then then this
one I think the proof is really
appealing okay so we have this this
class of functions and and you know the
random act complexity is like the
product through all of those L layers of
the scale of the the matrix that we get
in each in each layer okay so that's a
class of functions and that's the result
I guess it follows from this sort of
step in moving from one layer to the
next where we're saying you know fix the
fix the input the the the the sample x1
through xn and consider just the
conditional expectation averaging out
the the rate Omega random variables when
we look at the maximum over functions
this is a little confusing having two
webs here this is functions in some
class right which is the class of
functions you can compute up to this
point right and this is a Frobenius norm
of the next linear transformation this
matrix okay so we said so this
inequality says you know the expected
supremum over whatever functions you
have from the input to this point you're
maximizing over those you're maximizing
over the linear transformation that you
apply before you apply the non-linearity
and then look at those random arca not
adamak complexity it's actually a to
norm here right because we've got a
vector-valued thing so interested in
maximizing the two norm and at the end
of it all we'll get a 2 norm of you know
the last one of these is the output
matrix which is a row vector ok so the 2
norm ends up being the actual absolute
values we care about but along the way
we're considering scaler vectors and the
inequality says that thing is no more
than B which is the bound on the
Frobenius norm times the corresponding
thing for the functions that appeared
here okay so this takes us from a result
about the functions up to this point in
the network to one more layer right
functions at the next layer so you you
know apply this repeatedly you get this
to be 2 the number of times you apply it
appearing and then you know you want to
consider what this thing looks like when
you're right back at the inputs okay
which is inequality for that last piece
okay so why is this inequality true all
right it's using these specific
properties of the of the relu and here's
the key so if we think about our W as
having a bunch of different row vectors
right W 1 through W whatever it is K all
right so f is a vector valued function
up to this point and then we're applying
a matrix W that has rows W 1 W 2 and so
on then you know this is this is a
component wise non-linearity applied to
the components of this vector we can
work row by row split split things up
into you know first component of the
vector up to whoops first component of
the vector up decayed component of the
vector and we're considering the two
norm squared it's just the sum of those
things squared ok I've done nothing
nothing more than write out what a
Euclidean norm squared looks like but
but now when we're here we can use this
positive homogeneity property of the
the rally function we can scale
everything here so these guys have unit
norm all of the rows have unit norm and
the scale out there the the scale and
the denominator comes out here right we
haven't changed anything because we can
pass costumes through this non-linearity
okay so what's really nice here is that
then when we go and look at a supremum
right so so we've got that quantity that
where we've scaled things to have unit
norm here and the norm just appears out
there now Frobenius norm here is this is
a bound on the sum of the squares of all
the entries in the matrix so it's a
bound on the sum of these things right
the vectors the the Euclidean norm
squared of the rows so we can rewrite
that as you know what's the Euclidean
norm squared of the j throat let's call
that alpha J all right we need our sum
of alpha J's to be no more than B
squared and and that's it that's the
only constraint and these things of
course are unit vectors all right so now
we've got we're interested in and and in
a product now between something that has
a one norm bound of B squared and this
other thing that we're maximizing right
but but you know that's that's very nice
just take the supremum over the WJ out
and consider the inside supremum over
these alphas and we've got you know an
inner product between something that has
a one norm no more than B squared and
some particular vector right of course
we just want to focus on the maximum
value of that the maximum component of
that vector right that's this thing it's
the supremum over all I guess that's
this thing right times the value of
alpha one let's say right which is B
squared all right so we've gone from
well so there's still a little a little
step to do we have to we have to get
through this Lipschitz function we have
to work with the fact that this is a
vector
and and you know there are there are
some more details at the end to get this
in terms of just the supremum over the
functions when we start with a supreme
over functions so we you know we can get
we can get this kind of inequality with
another couple of couple of small steps
but you know the heart of the argument
is is there we're really able to focus
on just a single row of this vector and
and and maximize over that over that row
because of this nice positive
homogeneity property of the okay so that
gives us this a result of this form this
to be to the l divided by square root of
n so similar form for for for relu
suppose they're questions
okay I wanted to say a little bit about
covering numbers about another notion of
complexity and how it relates to
ratamacue complexity we'll see that you
know you can get up and roll bands on
random act complexity in terms of
covering numbers of a of a class often
this gives a very convenient way of
working with uniform laws of large
numbers particularly when things are
kind of end to end Lipschitz right so
you can exploit that that sort of
property and make a very very simple
argument using covering numbers that's
you know often another another very
convenient tool and actually you can get
in in terms of the kinds of norms you
can get an improvement on the the
relative results that I talked about in
terms of covering numbers because it's
linear of linear of linear but the
Lipschitz constant of the whole thing is
B to the L right so you have that
scaling of hearing through the whole
whole new way because remember we're
keeping a uniform constraint of you know
the scale that I can see from from input
to output is B at each step along the
way exactly right you know this is this
is a weak way of a strong way of
constraining things so yes it's the in
some sense the wrong norm we should be
working with respect to Norman you can
get this is actually the point I was
making about when I'm waving my hands
about covering numbers that you can get
results in terms of spectral norm you
know in terms of Tidy results in terms
of other norms using a covering numbers
kind of argument but not you know don't
know how to do it using right Omega
averages
but but not already forgotten seen you
have a bound per se these building
networks now originally they were
running on gravel depend on the data
stream but it bound if I'm not mistaken
no longer dependence for these for these
cases right so if we look at at this
result this says you know for every
probability distribution there's nothing
about the distribution here right this
is just saying you know we have an upper
bound that's true for every distribution
so all we're using is this sort of
scaling property of the class of
functions
so we've potentially lost a lot right it
may be that we've got a class of
functions that can do something very
very rich over here but the distribution
we have never illuminates that part of
the space so you know it could lose it
could lose a lot even if you know
uniform convergence is accurately
capturing what's going on in in a
learning problem we still have some an
additional source of looseness in D in
these examples yeah the argument said
can you isolate where potentially data
dependence might have been ignored
you know in some sense what's that yeah
it's a good question so so you know the
fact that we're not using anything about
the probability distribution is saying
that really all we're we're just
capturing the kind of scaling of the of
the functions that we that we can
compute with this this sort of class and
and that's telling us you know the kind
of rather make a complexity upper bound
that we get you know it's if if somehow
you don't you don't use the full power
of that you know with a particularly
yeah I guess I'm I'm saying the same
thing again but I I don't know of a kind
of concrete aspect of this class of
functions that you could point to and
say you know here's where a difference
might arise between different different
distributions yeah
yes question if only we could compute
miracle Rademacher complexities find out
right which which are concentrated yeah
maybe we could actually test it yeah you
know in the classification case for
instance computing empirical right ohmic
complexities is no harder than empirical
risk minimization exactly the same
problem
other questions alright let's say a
little bit oh yeah well doing I guess
along that line do we know if these
upper bounds are tight at least in terms
of asymptotic right so so you can what
can we say so if you if you for instance
keep to the linear part of the relu
everywhere
I guess as I've written it that's a
little strange because I haven't had an
offset here but you know imagine right
that we have an offset an additional
variable throughout keep the Li apart
we're computing a linear function in a
funny way but for those linear functions
you know it's really the scaling that's
that's important and you know modulo
that the norm i've chosen to give you a
simple proof you can't hope to do any
better
in that case right which is we're just
answering a different question to you
know is this the right thing when you
consider a rail network as as it emerges
from a stochastic gradient optimization
procedure
yes the bonbons on each layer separately
that's right yes yes so this is in some
sense an unnatural again again because I
wanted to present a simple proof it's in
some sense an unnatural unnatural class
right we're we're saying we have a
uniform bound across all these things on
the other hand you know you give me a
product of you can ship different of you
to visually oh I don't understand what
do you mean it this is the worst case
woman example even for a linear model
like right there completely orthogonal
you will get B power n uh-huh but if
they're aligned you get more like B
right so I mean you can not understand
you get you can get a lower bound for
the linear case by arguing that actually
we can explore the the full power that
this constraint this kind of B to the l
constraint gives us on the end-to-end
scaling right so you're saying it
actually we might not be using that much
now of course you know this may be one
example where you know this difference I
just described arises yeah
questions alright so I have five more
minutes okay so I'll say a little bit
about about covering numbers you know in
in some sense for completeness but I
won't spend very long at it so you know
the idea of a covering number is kind of
a natural thing when you see that you
can say something about finite classes
and and make the observation that
actually you know we don't really care
about arbitrarily fine differences
between functions
you know surely we should be able to
approximator an uncountably infinite
class with a with a finite a finite set
and that's exactly the idea of a
covering number so we have some set T
and and the idea of finding an epsilon
cover of this set where in a metric
space D here is not a dimension it's a
it's a metric it's a distance and an
epsilon cover of this set T is a set of
points that for which for every element
of T we can find some T had in our cover
some little T hat in our cover capital t
hat that's within epsilon of it and the
covering number is just you know how
many of those we need if we want to get
within this is a nice Center isn't it if
we want to get within Epsilon right
okay and you know and the intuition is
if you want to if you want to cover
something that's kind of K dimensional
then you need like 1 over epsilon to the
K right vaguely if it's sort of a fixed
scale then you've got a you've got to
get this this sort of exponential
dependence on on the dimension and so
you know often you see the log of the
covering number or the exponent in pull
out the exponent by considering the log
of the covering number right so ratio of
log of covering number to log 1 over
Epsilon that's the that's the metric
dimension one one definition yes the
asymptotics of that
so you know that's the that's the kind
of picture to have in your head is how
this thing scales as a function of one
over epsilon took to what power so the
log of the epsilon covering number is
sort of that relevant quantity and you
know there are upper and lower bounds on
ratamacue complexity in terms of these
covering numbers the upper bound is
saying if you consider if you consider
the square root of the log covering
number you know as epsilon goes to zero
is the is the way to think of it right
the infinity is sort of this sort of
irrelevant as epsilon goes to 0 you need
a you need a bigger cover to to you know
at some point where at the diameter of
our set right and we don't have anything
else going on up there
the upper bound says you know if this is
the square root of the log covering
number then the area under the curve is
an upper bound on the rate-o-matic
complexity this is due to dudley and and
the argument is all about approximating
things at multiple scales you know
that's where the integral rises the
lower bound is saying you know if you if
you find a maximal area a rectangle down
here that's a lower bound on the rather
macro averages those things could be
quite different right the integral and
the biggest the biggest rectangle and in
some sense that gap is inevitable
alright so this thing is the right thing
for maximal deviations between
expectations and sample averages
covering numbers you know it could be
loose one where they are but they're
very convenient to work with and you
know in one minute if you've got a class
that you define in terms of some
parameters and things are Lipschitz
right in terms of those parameters so if
you want to compute a function then
things change you know in a Lipschitz
way I'm just going to wave my hands then
it's really very easy to see that you
know you're just changing the scaling
with that Lipschitz constant right if
you can cover the parameters with some
number of approximation approximating
points then you can cover the class and
and you know this is hugely convenient
in in
with these things alright so that's
probably a convenient point to just stop
and ask if there any more questions
[Applause]
okay so I am
so if we actually go back to go back to
this result so you know if you're
looking at maximal deviations this
inequality says we've got the right
thing
these maximal deviations are the ones
that occur for that particular
probability distribution right so so
we're saying for every P I guess it
didn't spell that out but you know it
should have at the start for every for
any P for any G we have this these tight
inequalities and so you know the
specifics of the probability
distribution are baked into to these
things because this expectation is over
the sample that came the the random arc
of random variables but also the sample
that came from that probability
distribution so if it's you know a
peculiarities of the distribution these
things capture it but then when we go to
you know compute bounds on on those
things you know we may have lost we may
have lost that property right is that
what you're asking specifics of a
probability distribution generalizes
well but now if I this shock of my
labels and have random labels and the
same complexity is the number of
parameters and stuff you know I see
translation so in that sense you know
how we can do some of these forms like
the market complexity right so that's a
good that's a good indication that just
considering things like the I mean in
that in that example the scale actually
does change right when you when you try
to use the casted gradient to
- that's a train but to load random
random labels into a into a network the
scale does change so you know when you
when you're working with even the
inequalities that that may be that may
be loose they don't capture anything
about you know the natural images
whatever distribution okay April so you
know things are changing in some sense
they're right these these sort of bounds
on complexity that you see but you know
I really think you're in a different
realm from the sort of from the sort of
case that we're thinking about here you
know these sorts of deviation bounds are
going to tell you you know that the
empirical risk minimizer has expected
has true risk you know the popularity of
expectation of the loss no more than
empirical risk plus plus some quantity
right you know you you can use something
like this to say it has no more than the
best in the class plus plus some amount
but but actually you know you drill that
that's really based on these deviations
between sample averages and expectations
and the examples that you talk about the
sample averages end up being zero even
even when you add noise so we're going
to come and come to this you know in the
last lecture but it's a that feels like
a very different regime from the one
from the one that's that's relevant for
these sorts of results because they're
you're you're driving the the regression
loss to zero even if there's noise in
there right so so that's that's that's
kind of a different world from trying to
get something useful out of a deviation
between expectations and sample averages
you know that deviation should be big
because do you know you haven't you have
a noisy problem and yet you're driving
the the sample average to zero so you
know for for that sort of that sort of
approach I think we're not where that
that's in a different regime and I think
that's kind of one of the one of the
exciting directions you know we'll talk
about in in
in light elections maybe last question
yes could you go back to the slide on
the rail you
so why choose at the very bottom that
constraint on the provenience normal WI
less good question as opposed to say the
product of the norms over all eyes the
lesson rate especially when you've got
Sigma's that are homogeneous and so
scaling or the weights yeah
but then with that but that's the same
class of functions right so if I take a
supremum of this class of functions for
every function in the class that has a
product equal to some value I can give
you exactly the same function computed
with a uniform bound on each one yeah I
said that badly right if if the product
of these things is no more than B to the
L then imposing this uniform constraint
is just a shuffling the scaling
throughout the network using this
positive homogeneity property so you
know in this case it doesn't it doesn't
change anything okay let's take a break
a tool
[Applause]